four years ago julian assange wanders
into the Ecuadorian Embassy in London by
all accounts he's been living in a room
in that embassy since then this is a guy
who rose to great prominence first with
a video of helicopter shooting two
Reuters reporters a leak of State
Department cables what's he been up to
here over the last four years well so
WikiLeaks has sort of continued to
publish stuff as Assange has been
dealing with his legal situation he's
accused of rape in Sweden and he's
disputing the charges that's kind of
distracted the organization but they
really resurfaced in a big way in late
July when they published these leaks of
Democratic National Committee emails and
now as we report in bloomer and
Businessweek
Trump has Assange has been sort of
edging closer to Donald Trump and
basically seems to be trying to help his
campaign in in various ways that first
leak certainly provided fodder to Donald
Trump debbie Wasserman Schultz the
former head of the DNC had to resign
there was talk by Donald Trump and
others have an October Surprise emails
other materials WikiLeaks might release
closer to the election indeed we have
gotten some emails here from John
Podesta and others what if what have we
seen from WikiLeaks well so it's kind of
interesting there was this big event
last week where Roger stone and some of
the sort of sort of more I don't know
marginal figures I guess in the Trump
world were saying that there was gonna
be this October surprise nothing
happened a lot of people freaked out and
then just minutes after the leak of the
Donald Trump audio where he's making
vulgar comments about women Assange and
WikiLeaks came up with this leak of the
Podesta emails nothing huge in those
although there are bits of the goldman
sachs transcripts which was of course
like a big issue during the primary with
bernie sanders and certainly emails that
donald trump is now referring to on the
campaign trail he said an event in
florida today there's another event in
florida later this afternoon I'm curious
about what Julian Assange says about the
role he's playing here whether or not he
elected to play a role or he sort of
been thrust into it by releasing these
dogs so he plays it coy and he at times
he says different things at different
people we asked him and he's sort of we
said do you have any special affection
for Trump and he says I have affection
for all human beings which felt kind of
like a sort of wink wink kind of answer
to me
so so it's unclear what we're hearing
for people who are close to the
organization follow the organization is
basically that Assange and WikiLeaks
would prefer a Donald Trump presidency
maybe slightly not not it's not like
they're huge fans of the trumpet
possibility of a trump administration on
the other hand it's also a way for them
to be relevant
I mean WikiLeaks at its core I think is
a media organization and media
organizations they tend to go where they
can have an impact and WikiLeaks sitting
on these you know emails from the
Democrats it's it's tempting and they've
I think given into the temptation to
sort of use them to become part of this
sort of you know right-wing media circus
that that's happening right now where
you have you know reddit and The Drudge
Report and a bunch of other entities I
think that's what's gonna be so curious
to viewers as it was curious to me you
associate WikiLeaks perhaps more with
the far-left than you would with the far
right why would it be in Julian Assange
its interest here to have a trump
presidency I mean some people see it as
a betrayal I mean it Trump is in favor
of a lot of things that WikiLeaks kind
of at its core is opposes one one issue
is that you know when when those State
Department cables were leaked Hillary
Clinton was running the State Department
and Assange I think feels that she has
been pursuing him and I think there's
some question about just how vigorously
that pursuit has happened but he may
feel and I think he does feel that you
know a trump presidency would give him a
greater chance of getting out of the
Ecuadorian Embassy the evidence on that
is is it's not conclusive to put it
mildly I'd say